in this lesson we're going to talk about
direct variation so what is direct
variation how do we utilize it we're
going to go through an example and let's
get right into it so basically when you
talk about direct variation it's an
equation in this form of y equals a
times x like y varies directly with x a
is just what they call the constant of
variation sometimes your book will write
it with a k or even another variable y
varies directly with x so there's this
constant of variation you know that ties
together the two quantities so if we
know that basic formula we can utilize
it in these direct variation
word problems see if you can do this one
on your own and we'll go through it
together what it says here is that the
pressure in a balloon varies directly
with the volume okay when the volume is
80 units the pressure is 20.
find the volume when the pressure is 50.
so again go ahead and pause the video
see if you can do this problem we'll go
through it together
so essentially what they're telling us
here is that the pressure p
varies directly with the volume okay
so when the volume is 80 so let's put in
80 for the volume the pressure is 20. if
we solve for a by dividing both sides by
80 right
you can see that a equals 1 4.
so now we're going to do is we're going
to take that one-fourth we're going to
put it back in for a here we've got p
equals 1 4 v we have a more specific
equation that we can use
to solve so it says find the volume when
the pressure is 50. so here we can see
if the pressure is 50
what's the volume well we can do the
opposite of multiplying by 1 4 that's to
multiply by the reciprocal 4 over 1
and 4 times 50 is 200 so you can see
that the volume would be 200 units so
this is how you would work with a direct
variation
problem again you'll know that they vary
directly because it'll say
varies directly so one quantity varies
directly with another and then you can
set it up like this just make sure to
leave a variable like an a or a k as
your constant of variation and that's
what you're going to need to solve for
in order to you know make a more
specific equation that you can then use
to solve you know the final thing that
they're asking for so definitely
something important to understand i'll
see you in the next lesson